we are now turning now to the growing
outrage over the rise in
anti-asian hate crimes in this country
actress olivia munn is speaking out
saying
it just can't be open season on asian
americans
over the weekend as thousands of people
across the country protested
anti-anti-asian racism there were
four more attacks against asian
americans right here in new york city
one of the victims was leaving a protest
with her young daughter
this follows the deadly shootings at
three atlanta area spas
eight people were killed killed there
including six asian women
there have been nearly 3 800 hate
incidents against asian americans
reported
since last march in a year and that
number could be higher
because not all the incidents are
tallied olivia munn joins us now to
discuss
olivia it's really good to see you this
is such an important conversation i like
what you have said in the past
you said this we are living in a country
that attacking us
simply for being us i think that's i
think that statement
is very powerful how are you processing
all of this yourself
thankfully there is a group of us um
other leaders in the asian community
that communicate together on a chat so
that has been really helpful
but um it's been
exhausting and we
it doesn't really feel like there's an
end to it
um you know i speak with my mom a lot my
mom is still
really afraid to leave the house like
you said about
you know just four more incidents um
since all the protesting has been
happening and it's
and especially at the protest it's just
there's this feeling of like that
people are aware now people are hearing
people are seeing what's going on but
it's still not stopping
the violence and yeah i don't really
know what we're supposed to do
did you take note on the chat when the
flags were lowered in this country to
have staff that's never happened before
what did you all say about that yes
that was an extremely emotional moment
for all of us
um we we all just took a moment
and i think a lot of us cried i cried it
was
it was really important to have such a
important position in the world actually
say that we see what's happening we see
your pain and we want to acknowledge it
and
we have just gone for so long feeling so
invisible and our pain has been
invisible and the attacks in our
community
have been invisible and to have the
president of the united states
say that he sees us
made us feel that we were seen just
maybe just a little bit more can you
give us an example
exactly of the pain i think until that
listen we've been reporting on it for
the past year but i think until that
shooting
happened the spa it was like a wake-up
call for many people to say what is the
problem here
what is happening can you give some
examples of why this is so important
some of the egregious things that have
happened and are happening
well since the pandemic was weaponized
against asian americans we have had a
target on our back
and there has been so much violence
against us i mean the whole world we
all went into a lockdown and that was
extremely frustrating
for all of us and then we had
our former president give people
an actual target to put out their
frustrations and that was on
the asian americans in our country and
to say it's their fault
and so we've had this target on our back
and like you had said earlier that i had
said
which is that it can't be open season on
asians and it has been
and we have been beaten
slashed shot murdered
attacked screamed at and
and it feels like we are screaming into
an echo chamber
and no one has been hearing us and we've
been crying and pleading out for people
to hear us and to help us
and and then it comes down to what
happened in atlanta
and you know in our group we we've been
talking about a lot like what does it
how many
how many dead bodies will it take for
people to care
and it turns out that it takes eight
olivia
you're absolutely right it's taken us
too long to notice it really has uh i
want to ask you
you mentioned your mom and being scared
to go out and and i've heard that from a
lot of people you've also said your mom
taught you to speak out for what's right
but don't cause trouble
and i've i've heard some from some asian
american friends who said that you know
because of this sort of culture of being
of being more quiet they've struggled to
find their voice but are finding it now
i'm wondering how you're feeling about
that that's right you know my mom
is a vic refugee so i'm first generation
american
and when my mother and her eight
siblings and
her mother came to america they didn't
speak any english and
they all came here and they all went off
and got multiple degrees
i have an uncle who worked for nasa an
uncle who's a top engineer at ford
aunts and uncles who became doctors they
all became
really great citizens of america they
really wanted to add to the fabric of
our country
um but throughout that there has been
this underlying
kind of lesson in our life which was
don't cause any waves because as
second-class citizens in our own country
the idea that any of our pain or our
frustrations or anything could cause any
waves or ripples or
create any more attention on to us was a
really bad thing
and that's what we've seen with the
culture with
asians in our country and why there's so
much under reporting because
we really have been taught to to
literally take it on the chin and keep
going
that just to simply exist in this
country is enough that
we we we're not even asking to be
seen as full human beings and the fact
that
the younger generation my generation
we're seeing what's happening we were
raised right
by our parents and now it's our turn to
say to them look you paved all these
roads for us
now it's time for us to take you back to
the front of these roads
and walk down with you and show you that
you can be safe in this country and that
you deserve to be in this country
olivia thank you so much for being with
us this morning we really appreciate you
sharing all this with us olivia munn
it's such an important issue and we
promise we're going to keep covering it